Okay.
So we're,
uh,
finishing up on talking about aromatic compounds,
about the chemistry of benzene.
You know,
this was,
this was a big deal in the,
in the 19th century in part because you had reactions that were clean,
the compounds where often a robust and easy to purify,
crystallized and so on.
So it was so many of the early developments in organic chemistry,
especially in the second half of the 19th century,
had to do with aromatic chemistry nowadays that we have a more versatile
techniques for analyzing things like Nmr and for separating things,
various kinds of chromatography,
it's possible to work on a much wider variety of molecules.
So much recent chemistry's on other subjects,
but much of the classical work was on aromatic compounds and they still,
uh,
are important.
So the Friedel crafts reaction we were just beginning with,
and we'll talk today about,
uh,
some ideas about how you design syntheses and about Ben Zelig stabilization,
the reactivity at positions next to a aromatic system and about try fennel
methyl,
which was particularly important compound for the development of chemistry in
the u s so a subtext of what we're talking about today is how chemistry
developed in the United States.
Because as we mentioned last time,
James Mason crafts was an American,
but almost all his important work was done.
Essentially all his important work was done in France and published in French,
almost all of it.
Uh,
so although he was an American,
many people thought he was French.
You remember he,
he started working in [inaudible] lab essentially as a graduate student,
although he wasn't enrolled as a student,
I don't believe,
and met his,
uh,
seven year older colleague,
a student,
the first student of warts in that lab and they published a number of papers
together.
Then he published nothing at Cornell and Mit.
That was a textbook.
And then he came back to Paris and published this enormous number of papers,
a hundred papers in 17 years,
almost all of them with free Dell.
And in particular that paper or that set of papers in 1877,
which was the free del crafts,
a reaction.
Now,
how did they get into that?
They got into that because they had been students together with boards,
right?
And when he came back to work in free Dell's lab,
it was natural that they should follow up on what on the kinds of things they
were doing.
Uh,
at that time on the kind of thing that [inaudible] was interested in.
So seven years before that timeline started,
uh,
for,
it's published a paper on a new class of radicals.
And bear in mind,
this is 1855.
So this is just before Cooper and calculate got the idea of valence,
right?
So this was when types and,
uh,
and radicals were competing,
so of works was in France.
And he wrote this in his,
uh,
in his thing about,
a special reaction of iodides with sodium.
And if we translate that into modern atomic weights,
it's ethyl iodide and butyl iodide reacting with sodium to give Ethel Butyl,
right?
Those are his new rat,
new class of radicals.
So hexane plus two sodium iodide.
Now this is the infamous votes reaction.
You hear about the worths reaction.
The main place you hear about worths reaction is on the exam papers of
elementary organic students who figure you could make any carbon carbon bond by
taking to a halogens two to haylight ads and,
and treating them with sodium.
But this is a horrid reaction.
It gives terrible yields.
It was possible for him to do this because the products were often gaseous,
but,
but you,
but there was,
it was not at all a high yield reaction cause you get a lot of crossover.
You can get athlete with Ethel butyl with Butyl,
uh,
you can get a radical reactions.
You can also get a ionic reactions of the ethyl sodium and butyl iodide.
It's a mess.
Right?
So the question that occurred to these guys at 1877 was might other metals work
better?
Okay.
In particular,
how about aluminum?
So they tried reacting,
uh,
alcohol Haylight I'll heal chloride with aluminum,
with the idea of,
of getting our two and aluminum chloride.
That would be analogous,
analogous reaction with a different metal.
The question is,
does it work?
Right.
And of course they were chemists,
they did chemistry and chem is try as they said.
So they tried it.
Okay.
So what they found was it didn't give a very good yield of what they wanted and
it gave a lot of hcl and notice that that's very different.
It's not the metal that's reacted with the chloride,
it's the,
it's hydrogen.
Where did the hydrogen come from?
Okay.
And there was lots of that.
There were as many moles of Hcl is there were of the Lko haylight to begin with.
Right.
But very little aluminum chloride and very little of the,
of the r two right now,
when they tried to distill this stuff,
so they didn't get the gas,
but when they tried to distill,
they found higher boiling stuff and it was poor in hydrogen.
When they analyzed it,
that means that it had a lot of double bonds in it or rings or both.
Right?
So they decided it was actually benzene with our groups attached to that.
Where did the benzene come from?
Where did the hydrogen come from?
From the solvent.
Benzene.
Right.
And then the interesting thing about the,
about the aluminum,
they found that the reaction was initially very slow,
but the rate dependent on how much aluminum chloride there was,
as the reaction went on,
you've got a little bit of aluminum chloride in.
The more you got the faster at wet,
until indeed it was almost impossible to control the reaction,
although it started very fast.
So they began to wonder whether the aluminum had anything to do with it or
whether it was just aluminum chloride.
And they decided that was true.
They didn't need aluminum,
just aluminum chloride.
Right?
So,
so this is completely different from what they set out to study.
It's not an [inaudible] type reaction at all.
It's completely different.
You have to rearrange things.
It's an aluminum chloride catalyzed reaction of RCL with an aromatic compounds.
It's an aromatic substitution,
carbon radical goes on in place of hydrogen onto the benzene.
So this is a completely different kind of substitution from what they had set
out to study.
But notice that it's rather analogous to the idea of chlorine reacting with
Ketalysis by try chloro aluminum that we looked at last time where the try
chloro aluminum helps make the cl minus alleving group.
So it's,
it looks like it could be the same deal.
Of course,
this was mystery to them.
This,
this is much later insight about what the mechanism is,
but it's the same idea with our cl instead of CLC,
l a and in Pasta,
it's even possible that you could get sn one versions of this where the ALC l
three pulls off chloride and you have our plus if they are pluses sufficiently
stable.
Okay.
So,
uh,
they published this first paper in 1877.
The title of it was on a new general method for synthesizing hydrocarbons,
ketones,
etc. So a new way to form a carbon carbon bonds.
So you could have RCL and an aromatic compounds react in the ketalysis by ALC l
three and get the substitute of benzene and Hcl.
Now they say it's general.
So they tried a number of different things they tried are radicals that had one,
two and five carbons in this very first paper of just a couple of pages.
They say they took about five weeks to do all this work that I'm telling you
about.
Okay.
They also use bromide and iodide.
That worked as well as chloride.
They use Taleo Queen as well as benzene.
In fact,
[inaudible] was better because they could get it pure to begin with,
right?
So they say they could do it.
They had a system where they could keep the city the thing warm and,
and uh,
and try chloro Beth methyl chloride bubbling through.
That's a gas night and day.
So they ran it for a long time,
for several days.
They don't say exactly how many at 80 degrees.
And it,
of course,
you could do a substitution of methyl for hydrogen.
You could do a second,
third,
fourth,
fifth.
So from this they got Penta,
Claro and hexachlorobenzene.
Both of these were new compounds.
So a new synthetic method means a brand new compounds.
So no one had ever seen these before.
How did they know what they had?
Well,
in the case of the hexachlorobenzene,
they able to prepare several hundred grams this way it's melting point was 164.
Nowadays we say it's 165.
So they had very good stuff.
They measured the molecular weight and they got the correct value within 2% by
measuring the density of the vapor.
But an even,
uh,
a strongly confirmative,
a confirmatory observation was that they could oxidize it.
They tried a number of methods of oxidation,
but the one that gave a good yield was to treat it with cold potassium
permanganate for two months.
So that wasn't done in the five weeks.
Okay.
But they were able to get the Hex,
a carboxylic acid,
which remarkably enough had been known since 1799.
Of course in 1799,
they didn't know what structure,
they didn't know from structure altogether until 1858.
But buyer had recently showed that this compounds,
which was isolated pure in 1799,
I was hexachlorobenzene a heck a hex.
The carboxylic acid of benzene,
right?
Incidentally,
the source of it in nature as this is a natural mineral called honey stone,
which is this stuff,
right?
It comes in nature probably from oxidizing graphite or something like that.
I don't know where it comes from exactly,
but it was a known,
so once you've make a known product,
then you know what this new stuff is.
But the important thing was that they were able to make completely new compounds
and make old compounds in new,
more efficient ways.
Um,
okay,
so this was alkylation,
it's Friedel crafts alkylation putting an alcohol group on to benzene,
right?
So there were other Al collations they found out they could use,
uh,
an Lpl group that had a benzene on it already,
like a Benzel chloride here could react with benzene to give die fennel methane
that was already known.
Okay.
But this was a good way to make it,
or they could use chloroform and make and put three,
uh,
benzenes on it and get,
try Klara uh,
to try fennel methane.
And that was also known,
but what was new was that they could use carbon tetrachloride and do one
substitution,
then another,
and get tetra fennel methane.
Right.
Which was an unknown compound.
In fact,
it wasn't even known then because it turned out that wasn't what they had,
although it's what they said they had.
Right.
Because it's hard to know these things.
It wasn't that because it's too crowded to try to get four federal groups on a
single carbon.
Right.
Uh,
so it was try it.
So it only did,
uh,
it only did three substitutions,
not four,
and it was the trifocal methyl chloride,
but it didn't have chlorine anymore because they worked it up with water and the
water changed the chloride into it.
Ooh.
Right.
An sn one reaction.
So that was,
but that was a new compound for them.
Okay.
Uh,
but they found that if you use fennel,
Heloc pride,
chloro benzene,
if the chlorine was on the benzene ring,
then didn't react.
So it wasn't perfectly general,
but it could use Al Keel or air owl keel.
That is fennel on a,
on a carbon.
Right.
So you could have Benzel or,
but you couldn't have Ariel as the,
as the group.
Okay.
But then it was noticed that they also said it could use to make ketones,
how to bake a kito in that way.
So you start with a chloride that already has a c double bond o in it and acid
chloride.
And when they reacted a Benzo wheel chloride with benzene,
they got a dye phenol ketone,
which was a known compound.
But this was a better way to make it.
They could get with asset deal chloride,
they could get a fennel methyl ketone.
That was a known compound.
Here was an interesting one with uh,
with a dye acid,
chloride,
Valeo fluoride.
They could get a compound,
which I think was unknown at that time with two phenol groups put on.
So it could react twice or it could react twice with the same benzine molecule,
right?
To give that right.
And that was a compound that was known.
They anthraquinone so they could get ketones as well as opposite as a very,
very general reaction.
Very important for synthesis so that you could use a seal as well as Al Keel.
So you have free crafts,
not only free del crest alkylation,
but Friedel crafts accolation to make ketones.
Okay.
Now how would you do what?
What is the question mark?
What compound do you need to do a free del crafts reaction to get that compound
name the question Mark Leon,
what would you use?
[inaudible] good
one fluoro profane or purple cloth n propyl chloride,
right?
That compound.
Okay,
so does it work?
We'll try a warning.
Remember that once you put one out kill group on,
we talked about last time,
it becomes more reactive.
So there's going to be a problem.
If the product is 25 times as reactive as the starting material,
then you're going to get higher substitution instead of being able to get a good
yield of what you want,
right?
But the good news was that if they did it for five,
if it was done for five hours with aluminum chloride,
this was done by [inaudible] in 1940,
uh,
he was able to get about a 45% yield of mono substitution.
Now when you read yield,
do you often wonder what it means now?
Easily,
you'd say you get 45 as 45 is 45% as many moles of the product as you have of
starting material.
That's what you would read that now easily.
But that's not what they went men,
because if you used half the starting material,
so at the latter stages you have nearly as much of this as you do have the
starting benzene and it's,
and this and this stuff is reacting 25 times faster,
right?
There's no way you're going get the 45% yield.
Right?
So,
so what they mean is 45% of the product is mano as opposed to die try tetra
substituted.
Right?
So in fact,
probably only about 15% of the benzene was consumed,
but still they could get half of the product was mano substitution.
At that point.
Okay,
that's great.
But the bad news is that of the mono substitution,
it's not just the compound that Leon wanted to make it 60% of that and 40% of
the one we wanted right now that was done.
This is so that you could have rearrangement during the Friedel crafts
alkylation.
Now that was done at a slightly warm temperature,
right?
If they did it at minus six degrees,
then it turned around and you got more of the compound you wanted.
Right?
But still there's rearrangement somehow.
How does the rearrangement occur?
Well,
remember the aluminum chloride comes up and pull and starts pulling off the
chloride and makes a complex like this with the incipient cad I,
and it's probably,
it's not a real,
you wouldn't expect the primary cad I into form easily.
Right?
But,
but you've got the,
the aluminum attached there.
So it's beginning to develop a charge.
But if,
so,
that thing that you see there,
that complex can react with the benzene.
That is,
benzene comes in and displaces the ALC l four okay.
So you get the,
the intermediate with both h and the end propyl attached to the same carbon that
cad ion,
right?
And then you lose the Proton and you've got the product,
one of the products,
but the other product comes because,
uh,
so that gives the end propyl benzene,
but there's a hydrogen here,
right?
And so what else could happen when you start pulling the chloride away?
You can get a hydride shift.
Bingo.
Okay.
So the hydride goes there,
the chloride,
the cat eye and moves to the middle and now you get the other product.
But notice if you do it cold,
if you do it to minus six degrees,
you get more of the initial reaction before the hydride shift occurs.
So it's possible to get,
uh,
to get the product.
You want at least a substantial amount of it.
But you have to be worried about rearrangement.
If the cat die and that you're trying to put on is one that could rearrange to a
more stable cad ion.
Okay.
Now,
how about if you wanted to make seal elation?
Okay.
Uh,
there you don't get rearrangement.
Why not?
Because when you,
when you were making this cad ion,
it stabilized by an unshared pair on the oxygen,
right?
So it doesn't rearrange.
It's already the most stable cat eye you can get from that.
So with Acla action,
you don't get rearrangement,
but you need one equivalent,
not just a catalytic about of aluminum try chloride because it can,
it gets eaten up by the product by associated with the carbonyl group and by the
starting material as well,
actually,
uh,
that,
complex is that way as well.
But even though you've got a lot of aluminum chloride in there,
you can easily get rid of it just by heading water once you have the product,
right?
So now you have the,
this unrea arranged ketone,
but suppose what?
You really want it in your heart of hearts.
Leon was not the key tone you wanted propyl benzene,
right?
Ah,
that's what you want.
How can you get there?
By removing the,
Oh and replacing it with h two and their reagents for doing that,
like the Clemmensen reduction treat with zinc and hydrochloric acid.
Now that's a very strong,
acidic medium.
So maybe your compound,
other things in your compound wouldn't stand up to it.
Propylene Benzine is one thing.
A more complicated molecule is something else.
Maybe the thing you want won't tolerate acid,
but it will tolerate base.
Then you could use the wolf Kitchener reduction with hydrazine and potassium
hydroxide.
But notice it's done at 200 degrees.
So that's a very vigorous,
a basic thing.
Yeah.
If neither of these work,
both of them are cheap and,
and give good yields.
But if neither of them work there,
other reagents nowadays that you could use,
those are the classical reagents for changing the ACL to an Al Keel.
But the important thing to see here is that you've now been able to make that
compound without worrying about the rearrangement by going by way of the ketone.
Okay.
Now,
so that's a synthetic strategy,
right?
So let's think about what things you can get from benzene,
what groups you can put on using aromatic substitutions that we talked about
last time.
And also the Al Kill and ACL.
Uh,
El crafts reactions.
Okay.
We said you could put,
do teary Amman with d two.
So for chlorine on with chlorine and ALC l three or bromine with bromine and
Feb,
br,
three or other metal salts can work as well.
These so called Lewis Acids,
right?
Or You could use the Friedel crafts isolation and make a ketone or alkylation
would make an alk.
You'll talk about as long as it doesn't rearrange.
Right?
Or You could even put COO on with HCL HCL will protonate CEO to make the cat
eye.
And that then puts on Hco as a substitution reaction.
So that one will work too.
Or are you could put a nitro group on,
we said with nitric acid,
sometimes with sulfuric acid,
if you need it to be more reactive or are you can put on a s.
So three h that is,
so three can get protonated buy sulfuric acid and then the hso three could go on
and give these Sophonic acid products.
So there are lots of different things you could put on benzene this way.
Okay.
And in fact,
the sole phonic acid can come off again.
The,
so three can come off again if you treat it very hot with Steve.
Uh,
okay.
And you might wonder,
why would you do that if you went to all the work to put it on right?
And you'll see shortly why that is.
Okay.
Now you can also get other compounds by changing these groups into something
else.
For example,
the nitro group,
you could reduce it either catalytically with palladium or by using a reagent of
metal like tin and Hcl and get Anelyn the Amino benzene.
So an Otu can become an h two and then you could treat an h two with nitrous
acid,
right?
Uh,
it's,
it's uh,
uh,
sodium nitrite and Hcl,
the HCL protonate that you get nitrous acid and that changes Nh two into end two
plus,
right?
Which is called a [inaudible] compound.
Uh,
uh,
dies,
OBGYNs,
benzine die,
Azonian chloride,
that's called.
Now,
why in the world would you make that?
Well,
it has a resonance structure here that has plus on the nitrogen and that could
be the cad ion that does substitution,
electrophilic aromatic aromatic substitution and notice that you're making it in
the presence of something that's a very good,
very active receptor for that.
So you could make this compound,
which is important because it's yellow.
It's a yellow dye,
it's called Anilin yellow.
And it was the first such die that was made as a first of hundreds of these so
called Aso dyes that are all different colors.
I looked it up on the web to see if I can get a picture of something,
died with it and find that it's very popular for skateboards nowadays to use
anilin yellow.
Okay.
So,
uh,
but,
but hundreds of these were made.
This was where the activity was in organic chemistry.
This was before synthetic drugs,
right?
This was before plastics.
This was before the use of petroleum,
the way it's used nowadays.
So there weren't these commercial driving forces for developing organic
chemistry,
but dyes were important.
So the last half of the 19th century,
there was a lot of work on things like this.
So hundreds of these were developed and they have fancy names like Bismark Brown
named after the chancellor,
the Iron Chancellor of Germany.
Right.
Was a brown color.
And in fact,
that's still,
you noticed that that had,
there were two of these reactions that went on to give Bismarck Brown,
right?
It made two of these ASO groups in there and there's a zone.
I looked up a Bismarck brown on the,
uh,
on the web and find out that it's used as a histological stain.
There it is.
Okay.
So this was big deal,
but that's not the only reason that these dyes odium chloride was important in
two is a fabulous leaving group.
The n n triple bond is the strongest diatomic bond,
so it very easily leaves as end to it.
Notice that that's a very clean reaction to what it leaves.
What does it leave behind if you lose?
And two from Benzene Daya Zone,
Eum uh,
cad ions.
It's the phenol pad.
I am a cat eye and it's very hard to make,
right?
Because we talked about that before.
It's a very strong bond and not a good place to have a vacancy in the orbital in
an sp squared over.
It'll okay.
So there are lots of uses for this synthetic uses for the dye sodium chloride
besides making dies.
So you can treat it with HBR and copper bromide,
brust bromide.
See Ubr to put a bromine on in place of n two or chlorine on in place,
or cyanide on in place of,
in to now all of these reactions called Sandmeyer reactions after the guy who
developed the idea of using the copper bromide,
uh,
probably go first by an electron transfer from,
so you have see you br two minus an electron comes,
which is formed from br minus plus the copper bromide.
So that gives an electron to the,
one of the oral,
but one of the anti-bonding where it was a nitrogen.
So you generate this radical instead of the cad ion and a radical from the
copper reagent,
but that's very unstable and loses nitrogen instantly into,
okay,
so you have that radical,
but now these radicals react with one another to put the bromine on.
You have copper bromide,
which then adds bromide minus again and recycles.
So the coppers catalytic.
Okay.
So you can do it with also with chlorine.
Also with cyanide,
you can do it with iodide.
You don't even need the copper there because I minus itself could give the
electron to the dye as odium compound.
You can do it with BF,
four minus,
which is probably different.
That's probably not donation of electron.
That one probably does involve losing into from the cad ion to form the fennel
cad ion,
which then reacts with,
pulls off a fluoride for BF four minus.
Okay.
So that's probably an sn one reaction right?
Where and two leaves a great leaving group.
And probably the same for the reaction with water to put Oah on.
Right?
You can also react it with Nan o two to put an o two on.
But what's the utility of that?
Why would you want to do that?
Is that going to be,
uh,
you think,
a way you're gonna make your fortune to sell nitrile benzene making it this way?
What's the problem?
Yeah.
No,
that's not the problem.
He had no two here is a man I n n.
A.
N.
O.
Two is an AI.
All right.
We talked about not plus before,
but this is an ode to buy this.
So this would do the trick.
But commercially this is bound to fail Matt.
And you use that to get the guys?
Yeah,
that's where we got,
remember we,
where did we get the the die zone?
Iom Salt.
We got it from the mean where did we get the amine?
We got it from the nitrile group so we could run our factory day at night and
turn starting material into product at pretty good yield.
Right?
But you're not going to make a fortune in that way,
but there is utility for that but it's not obvious at first.
Okay.
And the same thing is true here.
You can react with hypo fos for us acid,
h three po two not phosphoric acid and that puts h odd instead of instead of the
end too.
But that's going even further back to benzine.
Why in the world would you want to do that while we'll show you what's the
utility of that one now suppose you want to prepare a certain compound like a
para Nitro,
chloro benzene.
Now,
how are you going to make it?
Well,
you could start with nitro benzene and we know how to put a chlorine on.
How do you put chlorine on?
What reagents do you use to put fluoride on?
What?
What in general,
to put any x on in place of age.
What form of x do you need?
What's the thing that does the attack?
X,
Y,
x,
radical x minus X.
Plus.
It's electrophilic aromatic substitution.
You need x plus.
So if we want to put chlorine in,
we need chlorine.
Plus.
Where do we get chlorine plus cl two plus ALC.
All three.
Alright.
Alc.
All three pulls the chloride off.
We have the equivalent of cl plus and that that'll do the trick except it won't
do the trick.
Why?
Yeah.
Why won't this work?
We talked about it last time
because Nitro is deactivating,
right?
It's make the reaction slow,
but still it'll happen,
right?
But not only is it deactivating,
what else is it metta directing?
It's not going to give this product.
It's going to give them that a product.
So are we out of luck?
Is there a way of making the Para Chloro nitro benzene?
How would you do it?
Okay,
Sebastian.
Ah,
start so that it's not going to work.
Okay,
but start with the but it because you'd get the wrong isomer,
right?
But if you start with the cl and put the night trow on,
now the reaction is more reactive.
Nitros a very strong or reactive reagent.
And chlorella is Ortho,
para directing.
So you're going to get the compounds you want.
Great.
Now suppose what you want is Metta Chloro,
phenyl hydroxy benzene.
That's the one you want to make.
So how are we going to do that now?
Because both Oh and C l r o throw,
para directing.
So we can't decide which one we're going to put on.
Furthermore,
we don't have the old plus reagent to put Oh,
on.
We can put,
we have the cl plus reagent,
but we don't have the old plus reagents.
So how are we going to get these things in the Meta position?
Well,
we could put the chlorine on.
Remember these,
we got Metta things by putting by that mistake we made before,
right?
And now if we could convert nitro to,
Ooh,
then we got the product.
We want any way of getting,
Ooh,
those of you with rapid photographic memories,
you convert Nitro to a mean.
Uh,
I think you can reduce it with this reagent.
I'm not sure,
but if not that when there'll be another one that allows you to reduce it.
Uh,
then,
uh,
h o n o converts it to the [inaudible] and water converts that to Ooh,
right?
So we were able to do it that way by way of,
of the nitro group converted and the Di's odium compound to,
Ooh,
the dyes odium salt.
Or You could also make it make it a halogen there or a night trial or an o two
or h.
But of course,
if we're n o two,
you could do it a different way.
Okay.
Now,
why would you want to do h
to make chloro benzine?
That seems stupid.
Okay.
So that,
that key reaction here is h o n o nitrous acid for converting a,
an Anilin that the Amino benzene into any of many different things.
Here's a picture of the Yale Chemistry class.
The Sheffield Scientific School in 1898 so a lot of distinguished looking guys
sitting here and they're showing the tools of their trade as we've mentioned
before.
But if there's a little box at the seed of the guy who's playing a flask,
like a Banjo here.
And do you see what it says on it?
Hot or cold?
Oh No.
So this is a little pun here.
It's Aho and no,
right?
Cause this is the chemistry they were doing at that time.
Making diammonium things and converting one thing to another.
Okay.
So suppose what you want to do is convert Tallinn into one three,
five try methyl.
What's the problem?
Just do Friedel crafts and put methyl groups on,
right?
What's wrong with that?
The alcohol groups,
our Ortho para directing.
You won't get this isomer.
Okay.
But what you can do if you,
so if you get,
if you try that,
it's got to fail,
but you could put Nitro Groupon in the Para position,
right?
We already talked about that kind of thing was chlorine instead of methyl as an
Ortho para director.
And now what we're going to do,
it's we've got not only the wrong group nitro instead of methyl,
but we got it in the wrong place,
right?
But
this is an indirect synthesis.
Notice what you can do is reduce it,
the nitro to a mean,
and now you could react that or if it's too reactive,
remember that the uh,
the rocket fuel was nitration of something like that.
You could acetyle to the fest necessary.
I don't know whether it would be,
and now you do the free crafts reaction.
Right now this is Ortho para directing methyl.
So it would tend to put it here or here,
but this is more strongly Ortho,
para directing because of the unshared pair and it would put it here or here.
Right?
So it's a stronger Ortho para director.
The methyl is that unshared pair,
right?
So it goes to there.
So now you have that Nh two group there.
So we've got the methyls where we want them,
but we got an Nh two.
What are you going to do about that?
What do we convert in age too?
What did the people in 1898 s do?
They treated it with h o n o make the dye odium salt.
Right?
And then react that with hypo fos for us acid to convert it to hydrogen.
So the not the nitro that then the Amino group was put on in order to direct
where other things are going and then you have to take it off again.
So there was a utility to removing it with hydrogen.
Okay.
Now here's the problem for you to work on how to make Para Denitra benzene.
With three h with three actions that we know about here.
So you could work on that on your own.
Yeah.
Now here's an interesting react,
a compound to four die nitrile flouro benzene.
Right?
And the interesting thing about that one is it reacts with an amine to replace
fluorine by the amine.
So this is an aromatic substitution,
but it's different from the ones we've been talking about.
Can you see why it's not like the electrophilic aromatic substitution that we've
been talking about?
What makes the nitrogen reactive?
Arvin.
Okay.
What makes the nitrogen reactive of the meat?
It has a partially negative,
well it's a,
it's a little negative recharge,
but that what's its high homo,
uh,
not that I'm sure.
Unshared pair.
Okay.
So that's what's gonna make it reactive.
So it can now we have nucleo fillic aromatic substitution instead of the things
we've been talking before,
our plus reagents,
cl plus carbon plus an Otu plus.
This is hi homo instead of a low Lumo.
And now that product actually is important.
I make it yellow because,
because it was used when you do chromatography,
if you spray it with this stuff where the means are,
will turn yellow,
right?
So we'll,
uh,
it,
so it was,
it's a good visualization reagent,
right?
And it identifies the amino acid at the end of the chain because if you put this
on the,
uh,
on the chain where the,
the end of the chain where there's Nh two and then Cleveland apart,
right?
And see what the pieces are.
The one that's yellow is the one that was on the end of the chain.
Okay.
So this stuff was called Sanger's reagent after Frederick Sanger who used it to
determine the amino acid sequence of insulin.
In fact,
he invented this way of doing it,
putting this color label on and [inaudible] he sent us a sequenced insulin in
1955 and then three years later he got the Nobel prize for this sang or did,
uh,
incidentally,
how would you sequence,
how do people sequence know the sequence of proteins nowadays?
Do they do it this way?
You know?
Yeah.
How do people know what the sequence of proteins are going to be?
They do it by sequencing the nucleic acid.
Right?
And in fact,
Sanger got the 1980 Nobel prize for s for sequencing DNA.
So we got two Nobel prize for they sequence city.
But this clever thing that he has a good chemist,
he figured out how to do is nuclear fillic aromatic substitution.
Now how is it well designed this reagent to do that?
Well,
for one thing it's yellow.
The product is yellow.
But another one is that this,
an eye on that you get by is very good because it's got a nitro group where the
charges right or there.
So it's activated for forming that intermediate by two nitro groups.
Then you'll lose the proton and then you lose fluoride.
Okay,
so the normal electrophilic aromatic substitution x plus comes on forming and
the intermediate with plus plus plus,
and then h plus leaves.
Now,
uh,
something minus comes on or a high homo,
the amine,
right minus,
minus,
and then f minus goes away.
Now why was f such a good thing to choose?
Because f generally is not such a great leaving group.
The other halogens are better as leaving groups.
It's good because the leaving is not the rate determining step of this thing.
The slow step is that initial edition.
So the more electron withdrawing the comp substituent is,
the better it will be.
So fluoride is the one to use.
So it's activated by fluorine.
So Sanger,
a great chemists figured out a good reagent and got rewarded with a Nobel prize.
In fact,
two Nobel prizes.
Now another place this crops up is in Nad plus,
which is this compound.
Have you heard of Nad?
Plus Nadh?
Some of you,
you will when you take bio chemistry,
if you haven't heard about it yet.
These are oxidizing reducing agents.
Okay,
so you have say an alcohol with a secondary alcohol.
So you have an h there and now you can do uh,
an electro fill,
a nuclear fillic aromatic substitution.
Notice what's going on to the Benzie is h with the electrons,
h minus,
right?
It's helped out by the unshared pair on oxygen coming in here,
And this then is a good place to put the electrons on the Asian.
So you get a ketone that it got oxidized.
And this Nad h right now,
the nice thing is that this is reversible.
The energies of these two are closely enough balance that you can run it
backwards and forwards.
That means this reagent can,
can be used either nad plus can be used as an oxidizing reagent and a d h could
be used as a reducing agent.
So you could make a alcohol into a ketone or ketone into an alcohol.
And this is a,
these are key molecules in biological oxidation and reduction.
And notice the way they do it is by transferring h minus,
accepting or giving back h minus.
So that's that nuclear fillic aromatic substitution.
So Ben Zelig reactivity,
uh,
was related to PKA.
We looked already remember what's the Pka of normal alkanes,
roughly the how acidic is our h,
just a regular old alkane,
roughly
50 something 50.
Phew.
Okay.
But if you have al Willick Age,
it's 43.
So it's something like seven powers of 10 or nine kilocalories better than a
normal Al Kill Group because of Alec Stabilization.
If you have fennel instead of vinyl,
instead of the carbon carbon double bond,
it's even two powers,
two powers of 10 butter or 12 kilocalories per mole.
And if you have two phenol groups on it,
die fennel,
methane,
it's much better.
It's another 11 kilocalories.
Better,
not quite as good as the first one because the first,
because there is not as high a homo anymore,
once one has begun to lower it,
so there's a little bit less.
What are you gonna predict what it's going to be?
If you put three phenol groups on,
yeah,
Luke,
you look ready to go on making a prediction here.
Pardon me?
How many Kilo Calvin's another 10.
It's three.
The third one doesn't,
does hardly anything.
Why?
Because it's so crowded that the phenols have to twist and don't overlap very
well.
Right?
So steric hindrance in Tryfan fennel methyl,
uh,
reduces the overlap with the or the anti and you want to stabilize.
So it reduces it by 25% from,
from Dai Fennel Bethel.
Okay.
So,
so the crowding is an important thing.
And this brings us to Moses Gomberg and the trifle methyl radical,
which is 110 years old.
This academic year.
It was announced in October,
uh,
1900,
right?
So October,
we were already underway in this class.
Okay.
So Moses Gum Berg was a speaker when this building was dedicated in 1923.
One of the featured speakers,
but he came from a very different background from crafts.
Remember crafts was,
uh,
was the son of an industrialist in Boston and could afford to go 17 years to
Paris to do is research.
Right?
But Gomberg was born in the Ukraine.
He was Jewish and his father got in political trouble and there were pogroms
going on.
So he and he and uh,
and uh,
and Moses left and came to Chicago where Moses as a boy,
he was born in 66.
So here he's 18 years old and he's working in the stockyards in Chicago for two
years,
but then somehow he gets to the University of Michigan two years later.
Right.
And here's his transcript from the University of Michigan.
He graduated in 1890.
So let's look at what he,
what kind of thing you would have taken if you were getting a bs in chemistry,
as it says up here at Michigan in 1890.
Okay.
There were distribution classes,
right?
So he took French rhetoric,
logic and psychology,
right.
And then these are science classes,
physics and math.
Right.
And here are chemistry related classes.
They're metallurgy,
scientific,
freehand,
hand drawing,
geology and mineralogy and chemical literature in German and French.
And the big one in the middle,
not too surprisingly,
is chemistry.
Okay.
So the distribution wasn't quite what it is here nowadays.
And here he is a student in the analytical.
Now he,
after his freshman year,
he Everage nine and a half chemistry labs a week.
That's labs,
not hours in lab,
nine and a half different lab sessions a week.
Right.
And two thirds of the more analytical chemistry.
That's where,
that's what he's doing.
He's doing a titration here.
Okay.
So there was no spectroscopy then.
Then he went after he graduated and got his phd,
he was,
I think the second phd in chemistry at the University of Michigan.
And it's interesting that he studied chemistry.
You might think as an immigrant with,
you know,
who had worked in the stockyards,
he would be trying to do some practical,
uh,
work.
Right?
So they're in this,
in this three year period when he was an undergraduate,
there were,
I think something like 250,
uh,
or no,
400 graduates in pharmacy from,
from Michigan and about five in chemistry.
And he took chemistry.
So that's very interesting.
But anyhow,
then he went to learn in,
in Germany,
in Munich with buyer.
So there's buyer 61,
the head of the lab.
And here's his assistant Tila who was 31 and here's Richard Ville Stutter,
who got to know who is 24 then the fair haired boy in the lab who got the Nobel
Prize in 1920 it's an organic chemist and here's Moses Gomberg.
He's 30 years old,
older because of his family history than these other people.
Almost as old as Tila.
Right?
But here's what Ville statter.
The Nobel laureate later said about it.
Moses Gomberg was teal,
his coworker in the student laboratory.
He was very reserved and modest,
kept entirely to himself and never chatted in or out of laboratory.
Some years later,
the work he carried out in the United States on the trifle methyl radical,
a case of try Vaillant carbon became famous.
And you know what?
I think the key phrases here
in the United States,
because remember crafts work was done in France,
right?
Nothing in the United States,
but here are just two decades later,
right?
The key work is being done in the United States.
So we're going to see how this happened.
This brilliant experiment,
one of the most beautiful and organic chemistry in one,
which few people credited at first gave great impetus to chemistry and have been
worthy of any distinction.
So he was nominated that,
uh,
Gomberg West for the Nobel prize a number of times,
but he never got it.
Now how did he get into this?
Uh,
well,
just before he got to the lab Tila,
the guy in the front row who ultimately drank himself to death in France,
uh,
had a student named Koisor who worked on this,
who made this compound called Ai be n Aso,
Iso Bureau night trial.
And from it in 50% yield prepared a new carbon carbon bond.
And this is a different way of making carbon carbon bonds.
Uh,
the way you do it is to lose nitrogen.
So end two comes out in the two radicals come together.
Okay.
So when Goldberg came along into the lab for just,
just a semester or maybe two semesters,
it was he,
uh,
he,
said under the sponsorship of Professor Teal,
I followed up on these reactions.
So he worked on this compound,
this idea of knocking nitrogen out.
And then he went for the third term to Heidelberg to work with Victor Meyer,
uh,
who had introduced the idea of steric hindrance.
This was a stressful time to be in a,
in Heidelberg because Meyer committed suicide during this,
this period.
But a interesting question and steric hindrance was this tetra fennel,
methane.
Remember Frito and crafts thought they had made Tetra fennel methane,
but in fact they had made trifle methyl chloride,
right?
Because it's so crowded.
So Friedel crafts wouldn't make it.
They tried with fennel and ions,
fennel metal compounds to make Tetra fennel methane and they couldn't do it.
So this was a real challenge.
A grand challenge was how to make Tetra fennel methane.
Not that anybody thought it would be good for anything,
but it was a symmetrical,
beautiful compound.
And how do you make it okay?
And Gomberg succeeded.
I have tried to solve this problem in a completely different way.
So the way he used those,
what he had learned the previous two terms in Munich.
So in Heidelberg,
he tried making this compound,
which you get from Dias,
odium benzine die,
Azonian salt and try funnel methyl chloride.
This stuff that Friedel crafts could make.
Okay.
So we tried it to see if it would work and it's 110 degrees with,
with copper there from eight grams of the starting material.
He got 0.3 grams of this stuff,
right?
How does he know what it was?
Well,
he discusses the Solubility,
but that's not a very good key to what the compound is.
Right?
But he did the analysis and this is what he found and this is the theoretical.
So agreed very well with that.
And what else might you be able to do?
The molecular weight would be very key.
And how do you get the molecular weight?
You can get it from the vapor density,
but this has very low vapor pressure.
Right?
But you can get it by freezing point lowering.
So that's what he did.
He tried freezing point lowering.
He had a,
he used,
he had 300 milligrams of this material and he used a hundred milligrams for this
purpose.
And he found that he lowered the melting point by 0.289 degrees.
This is real careful work.
He's being paid off for having spent nine and a half labs a week for three years
at Michigan.
Okay,
so by solve,
Oh,
is boiling point not freezing by the solvent boiling point elevation,
which implied 306 for the molecular way that you calculate three 20 so very
good.
So then he went back to Michigan to Anarbor.
He stayed there the rest of his life.
Right?
Working at the University of Michigan.
And what did he do when he get back?
I'll tell you next time.